well
i got this on sixth street
i used to have a regular eye now i've
got a black guy
[Music]
so when it comes to violent crime and
homicides in particular in austin over
the last year and a half or so we've
seen a dramatic uptick so prop a is
basically it is a citizen-driven
proposition that is to try to address
the problems that are dealing with our
police staffing crisis the increase in
violent crime that's been going on we
get a lot of problems in this town we
spend all our money on police we don't
have any money left over to spend on
anything else this is why i think prop a
is too much to too much and it's not
going to provide us with enough return
getting more police young cadets
couldn't do nothing in the city of
austin prop a is is a
helpful solution because that's going to
say the voters in austin the community
says we support you we want you to have
a staffing level that you can do your
job well it's unnecessary because prop a
solves none of the problems that police
have today
what proposition a does is
balloon the police budget without any
accountability it says two officers for
every thousand residents and 35 free
time with required trainings that's it
prop a does three things number one it
ensures adequate police staffing in our
city uh it does that by requiring uh the
minimum standard of 2.0 police officers
per 1000 population
madam koviak and the republican party
don't care about serving our community
they care about uh getting points on a
scoreboard number two we double police
training this is really important we go
from 40 hours to 80 hours that's the
most of any major city in america the
police academy tells us that will allow
them to include in the curriculum things
like de-escalation training which is
really important i think it's really a
disservice to the voters and people of
travis county as to how
the republican party um and matt
welkoviak have decided to
take this approach third we have police
reform
in this proposal everything in prop a
could be in place
now it could the de-escalation training
civilian oversight all those things that
were lies that were on camera caught by
me and other people
could be done now by the police
department you don't need a proposition
to do that you need leadership and apd
has lacked the leadership for almost a
decade to serve the officers and to
serve our community well so in the
summer of 2020 after the murder of
george floyd in minnesota the city
council here in austin decided to cut
the police department budget by about a
third what we're arguing about is not
defund which is a stupid idea it's how
much of an increase do we need to give
the police over the next five years
people here locally do not want to fund
defund the police efforts they do not
want to oppose the police and that is
what the no way on prop 8 campaign is
about it is about undermining
under supporting limiting the
effectiveness of our police department
that's why they don't want more police
officers hired
abd has a hiring problem they don't have
a funding problem and so i do support
them being fully staffed at the same
time they don't need the additional
officers or the additional funds
if they can't even staff the funds the
positions they have now
the reason that's happening is we have
no ability to replace our officers they
canceled the two scheduled cadet classes
we have a cadet class going now but it
will not graduate until march what they
are trying to do is create an unfunded
mandate that well maybe there's funding
there for property increases would then
defund our schools
defend our libraries defund our parks
and ems and fire yes we can afford this
we're asking for roughly the same number
of police officers that we had two years
ago we were able to to do that two years
ago why can we not afford that now
the answer is the city wants to spend
money on all kinds of other things and
not spend money on public safety the
problem is the law is poorly written and
it'll literally eviscerate other public
safety entities
and so i hope we can vote this thing
down and then we can all work together
to get the staff we need for all of us
will the city council have to look at
some of their pet projects and some of
their other discretionary funding and
decide they want to put that money back
into police services yes they will
the only way the police and ems and
parks and libraries and schools and
pools are going to get cut is if the
city council chooses to do that there's
enough money to do all these things they
don't even know us
the majority of them is white
half from us from lake way west lake you
know uh
cedar park
they're talking about their frustrations
with you know only white males and the
suburbs being police officers that's
part of what promptly is also trying to
achieve is to try to find ways to
that promote more diversity um
applicants they scared to come talk to
us you know um
what we need is our own police
are they frustrated at the police
because like i said earlier we're the
ones that actually show up and respond
it's not the district attorney it's not
the judges it's the police officers so
who else to bring your frustration to
but the people that actually show up and
you have a face-to-face conversation
with so recently the austin police
department asked the public here to
start calling 3-1-1 instead of 9-1-1
for a host of emergencies and certain
crimes uh citing in part the staffing
shortage that they have that they just
simply don't have the manpower and if
you've got a cold burglary call there's
not particularly a good reason for a
police officer to show up there's not
much they can do there they can't do
just as well over the phone
our office was firebombed just a few
weeks ago by a right-wing extremist did
you call the police when you were
firebombed
i was not awake when it happened it
happened at two in the morning
our neighbors uh the bar across the
street called 9-1-1 um and both apd
austin fire uh responded you have two
ways to deal with with your workload you
can either increase your workforce which
is through hiring more officers which is
what prop 8 is trying to achieve to do
or you can reduce your workload and
that's what you saw it took place
because we are not able to hire more
officers or we're not able to retain the
officers we have we're not having to
deal with addressing the fact that we've
got to reduce our workload and so that's
why you're seeing officers no longer
respond to
what they call lower priority calls
i want to live in a safe community and
for many for many of us we live in safe
communities
across austin and across travis county
this does not make travis county any
safer
it's a simple balanced thoughtful
reasonable proposal and i do believe
we'll pass